un peu trop fort jean-pierre moquer mais
non mais non parce que là c'est dieu qui
a puni celui qui voulait se faire passer
pour un infirme il est infirme et celui
qui est croyez en dieu et viril onctueux
et vainqueur c'est ça c'est ce héros qui
était muet qui parle
oui il parle il retrouve la parole et
l'autre qui je simulais là la firme it
est et reste infirme donc dieu est
intervenu donc on croit en dieu dans ce
film curieusement christine boutin
voulaient prendre à port leucate à
l'heure dans ce débat entre sommes là
les flamands ont du mal à trouver leur
place
non mais est ce que je voulais dire j'ai
cru que ces mots quilles avec intérêt je
crois que c'est un grand farceur
je pense que c'est un grand farceur
c'est ce que je voulais dire tout à
l'heure vous n'êtes pas une perceuse on
pourrait se retrouver dans une sorte
d'autel nom qui veut jouer le rôle d'un
chef d'entreprise à ces corrompus et
corrupteurs
si vous étiez juge toute la france qu'on
est en mise en examen à se retrouver en
taule non non mais le problème c'est
qu'il existe des personnages qui
évoluent dans le clergé dans la
politique et qui arrange des coûts ça
s'appelle des vallées blanc il se balade
et quand il ya quelqu'un
un prêtre ou évêque ou un homme
politique et qui est compromis on on le
met en examen mais après il ya cet homme
qui intervient et qui et empêche la
sphère de d'arriver à à l'arrestation à
la déchéance est donc là vous jouez le
rôle laval et blanc voilà je suis un
[ __ ] quoi un chef d'entreprise il est
triste d'être salo en fait c'est triste
de faire ça il ya des gens qui font 16
est pour ça qu autant de dossiers sont
laissés en plan le nombre de dossiers d
c'est en plein ce qu'on sait absolument
hallucinant il ya eu mille mises en
examen dans les yvelines dans l'est dans
la dernière année 1000 maintenant tout
le monde pique
hélas les prêtres
vous avez cité les yvelines par hasard
ou parce que vous ça vous savez que on a
un député des yvelines ici il ya un
début de ces crimes boutin qui est
député et même premier vice président du
conseil général des yvelines mais dû
être choqué par les fesses de ma
camarade
vous savez je sais ce que sont les
fesses je savais comment réagit la
parlementaire la femme politique là ce
que je dirais c'est que je crois que
les personnes qu'elles soient politiques
ou autres qui font des actes qui sont
qui doivent être punis qui fonde la
corruption doivent être punis comme tout
le monde il n'y a pas de raison qu'il y
ait des exemptions pour certains si elle
existe est-ce que vous avez pas monsieur
mots qui dit hier il y en a je pense
qu'il y en a mais je crois aussi qu'il
existe en france 500 mille élus qui font
leur travail sérieusement et honnêtement
et qu'il ne faut pas faire des amalgames
trop rapide parce que c'est la
démocratie même qui seraient touchés
est-ce que vous irez voir le film de
manquer pas pourquoi pas j'ai
l'impression que je veux dire répète je
pense que c'est un farceur et j'attends
la fin de la réunion a expliqué jean
botella ça suffit non on nous a crié en
traiteur notre image tout serait vous
montrez d'ailleurs où l'ange d'eau est à
nouveau transformée et reviennent à une
identité originale donc ça c'est la
première image imaginé par mocky et il
ya une deuxième image je l'espère qui va
apparaître
voilà non pas encore je vais trop vite
dans le montage voilà l'angelot qui
revient à un statut originel et
d'ailleurs c'est la couverture de cette
vidéo que j'ai entre les mains et que
vous pouvez voir l'écran qu'est ce qui
s'est passé jean pierre mocky là vous
avez perdu qui s'est passé que cette
gravure la celle qui était à la chapelle
sixtine
il avait une [ __ ] à ce moment là et le
pape léon xiii la supprimer et ensuite
l'église l'a remis je reviens sur ce
qu'a dit le monsieur de lixheim
l'épiscopat faire de la boxe il est le
père de la bosse il est extrêmement
jésuites c'est à dire il fait ce que le
fait tout le monde c'est-à-dire et dit
un peu de bien et
mal avancé le client d'un côté et c'est
pas bien de l'autre ceux qui vous
annulez ce que vous dites donc par
conséquent vous avez des affaires
étrangères nous avisent pour vous et au
développement at on dit n'importe quoi
je vous dit ça c'est bien mais je suis
content et puis après vous dit c'est pas
bien c'est qu'est ce que ça veut dire ça
veut rien dire ce que ça veut dire
encore comprendra rien je sais que la
principale et on ne trouve pas la
tranche et noir et blanc elle vous dit
pas oui c'est bien ça j'aime bien ça
vous n'aimez pas cela vous pouvez pas
aimé ça donner un peu d'argent aux
pauvres d'abord alors si jean pierre
mocky et là c'est que coûte combien de
films 40 films oui car on a fait un film
est toujours la bagarre avec ses curés
[ __ ] le miraculé et je suis allé là
bas alors de vous savez ce qui s'y passe
alors nous y avait été bon alors miracle
alors le miraculé c'est ce que les
conversions alors ma virée de la pas
pourquoi parce que je trouvais que les
marchands du temple exagéré il prenait
du pognon à toutes ces bonnes femmes qui
viennent prier et qu'ils sont sincères
alors qu'est ce que vous voulez en
arracher les affiches là les
représentants de monsieur là le monsieur
habillé en femme
donc le club qui m'ont piqué ils m'ont
arraché mes affiches à bordeaux car
c'est à bordeaux que vous les avez
arraché
j'ai zéro depuis un mois avait un casier
mais ça vous à vous insulter tout le
monde l'a depuis donné à beaucoup
d'autres partenariats saas pour être
bien et vous croient qu'ils réservent à
chez louis dimanche mort maintenant lui
non mais bon je ne peux pas te faire
voir du podium puisque ça marche pas un
peu de cas alors diplôme ainsi un peu de
chantilly dans l'oise à un prêtre mon
dieu tu sais pas comment il ya quand
même un minimum de savoir jean je sais
pas je n'ai pas de savoir mais mon vieux
alors comment arrêter regardé depuis le
banc intervenu tout à tout a basculé
dans l'agressivité
ouais vous trouvez que c'est par
agressive d'interdire le bouquin mots
mais c'est pas toi un bouquin moi j'ai
pas attaquer le bouquin je pense même
beaucoup de bien du texte rabon c'est la
grande mettez le à la
évidemment quand vous serez peut-être
qu'on les légendes entrée de jeu 13 ans
est facile de s'exprimer et nuancé les
pensées mais vous avez quand j'ai déjà
fait puisque fortement
[Musique]